talk sports vodka the Victorian off
secret catalogue be friendly agent ward
be friendly hey youtubers this week on
agents of shield it was all about sports
vodka and the Victoria's Secret catalog
I mean wait Oh second chances same thing
same thing we also got some new insight
into agent Coulson's miraculous recovery
let's do a quick recap of the episode
then talk about the big questions that
were raised and what we learned from the
episode so Agent Coulson takes the team
to track down Amador this rogue agent
that he used to Train he's trying to
bring her back into the fold it turns
out she's been co-opted by the dark side
the shadowy organization that's using
you're under threat of death so first I
have to mention at the beginning of the
episode when they make the call out to
supernatural abilities I feel like if
movies and TV has taught us anything
it's that if a character denies
something more than twice in the exact
same way it means it's totally true so
does that mean that ESP and supernatural
abilities like mind-control and magic
and other non science-based powers are
totally real I think it's safe to assume
yes but that's a bit of a red herring
because it turns out that Amador has
robot eyes there's these super advanced
cybernetic implants that shield does not
have yet so I think they just did that
to set up this shadow organization as a
credible threat they have way cooler
toys and speaking of toys let's talk
about fits so obviously they were
pushing the family theme really hard
obviously dad being Coulson and mom
being Mei so what about when dad found
baby Fitz asleep on his toys do cute
they've really just kind of hammered
home that theme when Skye was talking to
Coulson about watching mom and dad argue
downstairs obviously talking about
Coulson and May the funny thing is is
that Coulson totally allows her to use
that reference which means that he
probably thinks of them like children or
at least family members and that's where
we get our second chances team it's all
about bringing this amador person back
into the family personally I think
they're just kind of setting Coulson up
as being someone who's a little too
trusting that's why I feel like the sky
rising tide betrayal is just gonna feel
all the worse when it comes I'll talk
about that in a little bit though first
let's talk life model decoy so Amador is
talking to me at the end of the episode
and she says what's different about
Coulson what's changed she basically had
the ability to scan people like an x-ray
look she could see a tumor inside a
woman but structurally she could tell
when something was different but I think
that if Coulson was a clone she wouldn't
have noticed that he'd
friends she would look just like the old
Colson but since he's a life model decoy
as proposed by my theory here it means
that he has some parts that are a little
bit different like artificial parts but
let's talk about a couple of our
favorite moments personally my favorite
moment from the episode was that shield
family day trip the minivan trip what
else screams family trip like a minivan
obviously in that situation it's like a
- dad situation with Colson and ward I'm
sure there's some ships being born out
there on tumblr right now obviously in
that situation skies like the older
sister and you have the babies Fitz and
Simmons in the back so hilarious but
here are two big questions that we need
to answer in the comments one is Coulson
the life model decoy does he have
cybernetic parts and - who is this
shadowy organization clearly they're
going to be the big bad this season and
I'm guessing it's going to have
something to do with the sky Redemption
arc because obviously the rising tide
stuff is going to have to come she's
gonna end up betraying shield and then
she'll have to be redeemed so whatever
that redemption is it'll probably have
something to do with defeating the big
bad this season one of the things that I
forgot to mention a lot of people were
tweeting at Brett Dalton that he was
looking like Clark Kent when he was
wearing those fake glasses during the
episode let me know what you think I
think he actually is the spitting image
of a certain type of television version
of Clark Kent
like the Smallville version of Clark
Kent but he answered on his Twitter that
he's firmly on Team Marvel but who knows
maybe in the future I'm sure arrow would
love to have a Clark Kent cameo at some
point in Star City would that be awesome
as always if there's anything that you
thought was really important that I
didn't talk about be sure to write in
the comments and we'll discuss if I if
you really want to help me up please
like and share this video on social it
totally helps me out extra high fives
anyone the chairs I'll be posting my
supernatural episode 2 video tomorrow
morning be sure to subscribe to get it
and don't forget Wednesday is American
Horror Story and arrow season 2 then on
Friday is an hour long ledge in the core
episode and obviously Sunday is Walking
Dead so lots of TV coming this week get
excited right now you can click here to
watch all my other agents of shield
videos and you can click here to get
ready for that next episode of arrow
thank you so much for watching see you
guys tomorrow high fives
you